大家好,我是老猫,欢迎来到老猫指标
这是一个致力于测试各种股市指标和策略
以及分享技术分析知识的频道
大家新年好
祝大家在牛年里牛气冲天
牛运亨通,牛股相随
那么今天我们讲一个经典的交易系统
海归交易法
据说一个用400美金赚到2亿美金的交易法
海归交易法是由美国期货大师Richard Dennis
在一个交易员培训班上推广而闻名于世的交易系统
据报道说他用400美金作为启动金
几年后在26岁就成了百万富翁
那个时候是197几年
上百万美金别说在那个年代
即使换到现在也是一笔巨款了
当时Richard想搞清楚
优秀的交易员到底是先天的还是后天培养的
然后他就在1983年的时候开启了海归计划
在社会上招募了上千人
然后从中挑选了十几个人
培训他们一周
然后给他们20万到200万美金不等的筹码
让他们机械式的用海归交易法去交易
几年之后
100%所有学员都盈利
并且取得了年均福利80%的收益
注意哦
年福利80%是很牛逼的百分比
基本上4年就能把本金翻10倍
那么最终这个海归团队
也给Richard赚了超过1亿美金的收入
之后当海归团队解散后
他的学员都被挖去当了基金经理
但由于当时所有人都签了10年保密协议
所以直到十年后的1993年
这个交易方法才被泄露出来
虽然光听这个故事
海归教育法应该很牛
但据说Richard在1987年股灾的时候
也是被腰斩
资产损失进半
随后在1988年
他就退出了金融界
所以由此可见
任何交易法都不能百分百必胜
哪怕是一个让本金翻了无数倍的
这样一个交易系统
那么这个海归教育法
如果要细讲
估计老毛讲几期也讲不完
因为里面包含了具体的交易细节
比如说选择什么市场
仓位要多少
什么时候买
什么时候卖
止损怎么设
什么时候手动平仓等等
这里老毛只简单讲一下
其开仓和平仓的机制
简单来说
它就是一个突破交易法
在海归交易法中
分短线和长线两个机制
短线机制是
当价格突破20最高价
就做多
当价格跌破10日最低价
就平仓
长线机制是
当价格突破55日最高价
就做多
当价格跌破20日最低价
就平仓
那么这个是做多的机制
做空就用同一个逻辑反过来操作
那么老猫通过这个逻辑
简单做了一个指标
接下来我们到图表中去看一下
好我们来到了
TradingView的图表中
那么老猫已经把自定一个指标添加到了图表上
那么通过海规交易法的逻辑
不难画出20根K线的最高价和最低价
可以看到老猫把这个通道给做了出来
如果用过唐奇安通道的小伙伴
你可以发现实际上这就是一个唐奇安通道
那么这个TradingView也是自带有这个唐奇安通道的在指标里边搜索DC你就可以看到这个唐强通道那么这个唐强通道就是计算20根K线的最高价和最低价
然后画出一个通道
然后中间这个黄线
就是最高价和最低价的一个平均值
那么这个唐强通道的作者也叫Richard
那么这个作者发表这个指标
是早于海归交易法的
所以当这个海归交易法公布于众的时候
大家就恍然大悟
这实际上就是一个更新版本的唐秦安通道
等于说海归交易法沿用了20根K线的最高价作为入场
然后简单改良了出场的时机
使用了10根K线这样的周期作为出场的时机
那么这边老猫为了看图方便
用红色代表空头
蓝色代表多头
那么同时
把这个买卖信号给加了上去
然后在中间画了一条多空的一条分水岭
那么等于说如果当K线
超过这条多空分水岭的时候
就做多
那么反之在支下的时候就做空
那么我们可以看到
如果使用默认的海归交易法
有很多的开仓交易机会
那么为了避免逆时交易
老猫添加了一个周期为55的EMA
作为过滤
等于说在这个传统的海归交易法上面
做了一个非常简单的改良
在EMA之下的时候
我们才会去考虑做空
反之在EMA之上的时候我们才会去做多
那么我们可以看到
这边我只使用了短周期交易系统
那么如果我们使用长周期55和20
也是可以的
那么为了测试方便
我们这一次只使用了这个短周期的交易系统
所以我把这个EMA周期设置为55
那么我们可以看到
使用了EMA过滤之后
可以减少一部分逆势交易
从而增加我们的成功率
那么为了测试方便
老猫继续使用TradingView这个StrategyTester
让它自动帮我测试
这样老猫就不需要去手动测试100次了
那么我们简单来看一下这个策略的结果
首先是日线的黄金
我们可以看到胜利大概是35%左右
然后资金曲线走的也不是非常平稳
但是还是可以赚钱的
我们再看一下日线的盈
那么胜利欲就是35%左右
然后资金曲线图走的也是非常崎岖
那么经过100多次的交易之后
还是可以赚钱的
那么再来看一个期货
原油
那么原油也是差不多35%到40%之间的一个胜率
经过100多次的交易之后还是可以赚钱的
但是这个资金曲线走的是非常崎岖的
说明稳定性比较差
那么我们再来看一个商品期货天然气
那么这个天然气的胜率有40%
经过200多次的交易之后还是可以赚钱的
但是这个资金走的是非常崎岖
非常不稳定我们再来看一下常见的股值比如说SP500那么SP500也有超过40%的胜率
经过100多次的交易之后
还是可以赚钱的
但是这个资金曲线图走的也是非常不稳定
那么估计纳斯达克和道琼斯都大同小异
日经也是差不多
100次以上的交易之后
有40%左右的胜率
资金曲线显示还是可以赚钱的
那么我们来看一下中国的股票
那么这个A50
这个交易次数比较少
那么我们也不好做评论
上证
那么这个上证经过181次交易之后
胜率有38%左右
那应该说跟美国的股指的胜率差不多
那资金曲线走的也差不多
再来看一下恒生指数
那恒生指数经过200次的交易之后
胜率也是差不多38%左右
那么说明在股指方面
胜率差不多在35%到40%之间
那么我们再来看一些外汇
美元对日元
那么美元对日元
这边资金曲线走的也是依旧非常崎岖
经过200多次的交易后是亏钱的
再来看一个美元系的货币对
美元对家元
那么经过200多次的交易后是亏钱的
那欧元也是200多次的交易后是亏钱的
顺率只有30%多一点
那么再来看一个英镑吧
那么英镑走的是非常崎岖了
那么经过150多次的交易后
还是可以赚钱的
那么由此可见
在外汇货币对中
这个交易是不太容易可以稳定赚钱的
那么我们再去看几个美国的股票
比如说苹果
那在股票方面
它这个资金曲线图走的就比较好看了
那么如果选一个比较好的股票
长期拉大周期看
永远是多头
所以我们可以看到
这个胜率在35%左右
赚钱超过了100%
经过282次的交易之后
美国银行
经过400多次的交易后
也是可以赚50%以上的利润
胜率是40%左右
JP Morgan
那JP Morgan这个资金曲线
走的就比较坎坷了
那么经过400多次的交易后
胜率是38%左右
那利润只有14%几
那么我们可以再去试一下小级别
因为我们这边用了日线图
我们可以去试一下小级别
比如说黄金的一小时
那么黄金的一小时
经过100多次的交易之后
胜率也是35%多一点
然后也是可以赚钱的
然后这个资金曲线图走的还是可以
如果我把它换成4小时
那么4小时这个线走的就比较坎坷了
每一次赚钱之后就有一个回撤
赚钱回撤回撤
回撤幅图比较大
那么我们来试一下SP500
1小时
那1小时里边走的就不是那么好了
換成15分鐘15分鐘也是一樣5分鐘也是一样所以看来对于比较小的级别由于小周期里边假突破特别多
所以可能相对来说在大一点的级别里边
这样的突破会比较有效一点
那么我们再来看一下具体的盈利情况
比如说这个黄金
虽然这个胜率只有35%左右
但是老毛发现最大的盈利的一单是1万美金
最大的亏损只有1700美金
再看一下苹果
那么这一点在苹果这边也是一样
最大的盈利有2万美金
最大的亏损3600多美金
由此可见
这套系统如果在追随一个比较不错的趋势的时候
是可以盈利非常多的
比如说这个比特币在这边进行开仓之后
它就会一直持有
一直持有
直到现在一直持有
因为它这个线还没有跌破这个多空分水龄
等于说它这单拿下去
会有不错的利润
最后总结
老猫觉得这个海归交易法
经过这么多年的使用之后
已经不是那么有效了
老猫觉得主要有以下三大问题
第一个问题
在很多情况下
价格突破了一个高点之后
很容易会回撤
那么这个回撤之后
就会吐掉很多的利润
所以要等到跌破10根K线的最低价再出场
可能这个出场的时机并不是太好
第二
这个策略的胜率不是太高
我们可以看到很多胜率就只有35%左右
而且可能会经历连续的亏损
那么如果你对于资金管理
没有做得那么好的话
很容易就爆仓了
第三不稳定
那么不光是这个资金曲线图
我们可以看到很多时候
在不同的品种上面
稳定性是不一样的
这一点也在Richard自己
和他的海龟们身上所验证
因为他自己最后亏钱
也是使用了这套系统
同时这个海归教育法
对于不同执行能力的人
会有不一样的结果
后面的海归
他们那些学员
有的赚钱
有的亏钱
但是他们使用的是同一套系统
那么总的来说
老猫觉得
这个海归教育法
有一点值得我们学习
那就是趋势教育法
一旦突破
就跟随那个突破的方向去操作
换句话说
就是追涨杀跌
老猫认为追涨杀跌
实际上是一种趋势跟随的策略
并没有什么不好
那举个例子
比特币
那么比特币老猫在这边
突破4万2000美金的时候
追多
然后止损
就设在
3万9999
那么突破高点追多
我觉得是一点都没有问题的
但是要带好非常浅的止损
好了
那么这一期关于海归教育法
我们就讲到这里
欢迎大家留言评论转发
谢谢
最后还没关注和订阅的朋友
如果可以的话
麻烦帮忙关注和订阅一下
您的支持
使我持续做更好视频的动力
我是老猫
谢谢观看
我们下期再见
by bwd6